I'd like to feel both my generator tank  and then the heating tank to do that I  got a run the Bobcat when the Bobcat  broke down the motor was still running  strong the power and drive issues work  leads me to believe it's hydraulic if I  can get it to turn over while it's all  warming up then I'll use the power from  the battery to do the fueling here  disconnected shut it down check the  hydro level but more and if I need to  hopefully that's it  I'm gonna shut this down it's warmed up  I'm going to check my hydro low  pull them out  and he spoke  so much for an easy pigs what I'm  probably gonna just try to do since the  hydraulic fluid is great the next thing  I can do is turn it over ask it to go  forward get it out there try and lift  something in the bucket see if it does  it again  you